hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
be doing a review of one of the websites
was part of my fiverr gig here we're
going to be reviewing a website giving
my feedback so this one comes in from
Marco pascua he says is an inspirational
speaker from Vancouver and wanted me to
check out his website called acute
principles so let's check it out and see
what kind of feedback we can give him
here so the website loads so it's a it's
great that I can see who you are I love
the picture here I see there's a video
here it's called the cube principle so
this is I like the tagline Marco
presents the cute principle makes me
want to learn a little bit more about
what that is it's a it's kind of catchy
get motivated and level up your life
through laughter fun and inspiration so
a good catchy tagline you're curious a
little learn a little bit more about
what you do here logo is interesting
create utilized best energy not sure
that's the best tag line but everything
else up here is looking pretty good your
font is really hard to read i'm noticing
in the knife here home about speaking
get out there the font is really
difficult to read you may just want to
do some compatibility testing with
browsers i'm using chrome here to do all
my video so you may want to check that
out and make sure it's working in
different browsers as I scroll down it's
great that you have the video people can
quickly learn about what you do is wish
if you're you said in your email at your
speaker so it's great to be able to see
you speak you have a login here and a
password or new user I don't know why I
would sign up for this so you probably
want to put some information here about
the benefits of becoming a member or
signing up or what you get because that
takes up a big chunk of your space here
on your homepage and you want to make
sure it's really important it looks like
it also stretches your page this banner
doesn't quite go all the way the top or
to the right here and it may be because
this section here is taking up too much
space so something worth looking at at
least but you know I'm assuming if your
speaker you want to get people to hire
you to speak so I would presume that
that information you want to make more
accessible and higher up than something
like this a login where it's a little
bit
choosing as to why somebody would want
to log into your site so we talked about
the font being hard the radii we see
that more here as well I can kind of
read what it's all about but it's a it
may just be an issue with chrome or
maybe a compatibility testing across the
different browsers so let's learn a bit
more but you do Cuba's an acronym stands
for creatively utilize your best energy
okay so now I understand what it means I
didn't get that from here so first you
use create instead of creatively but you
may want to make these capital letters
so they stand out a little bit more to
increase the font size a little bit so
we understand the cube stands for
creatively utilized your best energy
that's great see learn a little bit more
what you're doing q principle and comes
the same kind of approach practical
system that can be applied to these
challenges a lot of you recognize a
challenge successful what you need to
overcome it and how to put positive
energy into action help you reach any
milestone so not bad it's a little kind
of high level a lot of people will say
those things it's try to maybe break
down your Q principal a little bit more
but I'm also not quite sure what you do
if I just come to this page if you
didn't tell me that your speaker I'm not
sure what you're selling here are you
selling coaching services are you
selling your speaking are you selling
books or CD programs so you may want to
exclude explained here on your homepage
what it is that you do so that when
people come and visit maybe they'll
check out the video maybe they don't see
your top nav you want quickly in the
homepage explain what it is that you do
and why they should why they should
don't care so I'd also try to put more
text on here because it's not a lot of
text and if you're trying to rank in the
search engines it's good to have a lot
more text on the page so it'll track
more visitors to come in so let's learn
a little bit more so that's the end of
the page here I see your twitter feed
let's look at your speaking and see what
it's all about here this is great that
you can show so here's a list of
different things where you've done so
speaking this is great at schools I can
quickly click on play and watch any of
these if I want to and it's always good
for anybody who does speaking to show
examples of them speaking so that
potential clients can see you in action
and learn
little bit over what you do on the right
side here we've got this level up your
life so I'm assuming this is one of your
programs recognize a challenge assess
what is needed to overcome it use their
best energy to guarantee success so you
know again kind of high-level a lot of
people will say these kinds of things so
it may be worthwhile looking at using
some language it helps separate you from
all the other guys who are coming and
trying to pitch their programs I'd also
clearly explained what the program like
how long it is so if you're being booked
for a speaking gig clients want to know
how long are you coming to speak for and
who your target audience is so you're
targeting events you targeting
corporations individuals you know who
are you going after so the more clearly
you can explain that the easier it's
going to be for your clients to
self-identify and say yeah we should we
got to hire this guy one of them on
board and again you'd want more text on
here to keep people on the page longer
and help convince them to contact you
but also to help you rank better in the
search engines I'd also have some kind
of call to action here I'm sure you have
something up the top yeah contact but
you want to have a call to action here
so if somebody's reading this they've
landed on your speaking page there
they're kind of interesting to what you
do if they read all this you want to
just say is the next step you know email
me or call me just to increase your
conversions a little bit more on that
side let's see what else we have here
let's look at your blog so it looks like
your blog you're just using a frame and
it looks like it's a blogspot blog let's
check a look at it okay so look at this
everything's done in flash which is
going to be harder to rank it's still
possible but a lot harder to rank so you
may want to look at modifying that a
little bit and if your content if I look
here if I hover over here in the bottom
left very bottom left of the screen I
can see this it's going to Marco
possible blogspot CA if you're creating
content you want to try to put that on
your website as much as possible so you
can rank instead of having to go to a
blogspot page so I think
moving your blog over to have it as
actually part of your page so you can
increase your organic traffic to your
site that will really help but it's look
at you're creating some good content and
long content here and that is a great
way to help drive some doctor to your
website so this is a good start and then
maybe one more page with your
testimonials again that people
testimonies are great because it shows
that you know clients are happy with
what you're doing still hard to read but
you have some branding clients this is
fantastic so you know bank of montreal
huge bank up here in canada that's a
brand name client and see what else we
have I don't know sunshine foundation
but looks good safeway safeway women's
networking group and down so this is
great if you have a client like Bank of
Montreal and somebody's saying how great
you are I put this on more than just
your testimonials page don't make people
dig to find it I put it on the homepage
and I put it on your speaking page as
well so right away people can see that
you're serious that you have some major
clients here's you going up against
people who have a website that may look
great but they don't actually have a
great product or service to offer and
because you look young that's probably
going to go a little bit against you and
assume that you're just getting started
out I may not be able to offer a lot of
value declines so showing that you've
worked with Bank of Montreal and they've
had a positive experience with you I put
a quick quote on the homepage maybe a
picture of Mark if you can find them
somewhere do a linkedin search and the
bank montrell logo and also on the
speaking page and either rotate them
through because you have a couple brand
name clients here or just use one and
have it static I think that could really
help your conversions as well so
hopefully there's a few ideas in there
for you Marco good website could be
maybe a little bit better but hopefully
that helps give you some ideas for those
of you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below what
makes want to do more of these for you
and if you have a question about this
website or a question what your own
business feel free to leave it in
comments below I always read those love
seeing them come in and look forward to
be able to answer them for you so take
care and we'll see you on the next
episode